bonjour isabelle
talent ça va tu vas bien
non ça qu'est ce qui était arrivé au
bras tu t'es fait mal
qu'est ce qui s'est passé hier j'étais à
moto ouais
c'est à moto
quand une voiture devant moi d'accord on
avait une voiture devant
n'avait pas vu un piéton traverser elle
a une personne qui est passé devant la
voiture
le feuilleter vers le ferait
alors la voiture a freiné brusquement et
moi j'ai percuté la voiture pas rallié
derrière
je me suis cassé le bras
tu dois avoir mal oui après sais pas
c'est quoi tes par terre tu es tombé
quelqu'un a appelé les pompiers
pompiers
des pompiers les pompiers qui sont
arrivés d'accord
on m'a mis sur une civière et on m'a
transporté à l'hôpital
hôpital
tournée ou
à l'hôpital et emmené à l'hôpital
d'accord et après après l'hôpital le
médecin
dans les
médecins
le médecin le docteur d'accord le
médecin
un an s'est cassé
cassé
à
alos
luz casser quoi
tu as mal oui j'ai très mal d'accord ils
m'ont mis un bandage
mais la bande à
la moto la moto allait casser la moto
non mais c'est important la mode tout
cas moi je tu te fous de moi non mais
non c'est pas ça mais la moto pour la
moto
non même bien sûr que signe un retour
c'est quand même important dans mon
excuse moi je suis désolé vraiment
désolé pardon pardon temps
moi je vais y aller ouais au revoir
pour revoir
bonjour
hier
accident
pompiers
hôpital
mal
mes deux seins
boss
cassez
au revoir